the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video all right my
friends in this video i will be
discussing hbo's 30 million dollar
failure some of you may or may not know
this but before hbo started filming
house of the dragon there was another
show they were developing that was also
set within george rr martin's a song of
ice and fire universe is this can i ask
one one of the
hbo shows and development can you tell
us about any of those by the way blood
moon is wrapped something has i i can't
uh go on
there's probably an hbo agent in the
in the auditorium even now um i can say
as i have said before we we started out
with a number of different ideas all of
them prequels
um
one show uh
which i've been calling the long night
what hbo keeps saying it's not titled
yet so the show that's not called the
long night
uh
yet
has
just finished uh filming up in belfast
and is now and and other places not just
belfast italy as well and uh jane
goldman is the writer and the showrunner
on that uh
you you've probably been familiar with
her work she uh was the scriptwriter on
several of the x-men movies she did kick
ass
and she did the uh the kingsman both
kingsman
uh things she she scripted neil gaiman's
uh stardust so she's a very experienced
screenwriter
and she's done this story and it is set
you know 5 000 years
in the past of westeros so way
way way before the events of game of
thrones and that that's the one that is
uh furthest along at the moment and it's
in reproduction and right now it's just
a pilot but it's got uh naomi watts in
it starring it's got miranda richardson
a lot of other very uh exciting actors
and uh
we'll probably be finding out in the
next couple months whether hbo is
actually going to order a full
the full series of that
and meanwhile we have two other pilots
that are also in
active development at some stage and
hopefully
in the near future
one or both of them will be green lit to
shoot a pilot
that's right folks before house of the
dragon there was the long night a series
that would have been set in westeros
focusing on the starks of legend as well
as the origin story of the white walkers
the long night would have been set
thousands of years before the main
events in game of thrones now i don't
know about all of you but i was very
excited for this show as a matter of
fact i would still rather see a show
about the long night rather than one
about the dance of dragons but maybe
that's just me i've always been far more
interested in the legends and the
mysteries of the north like the founding
of house stark and what i believe is
their connection to the white walkers
and the night's king i was actually
devastated when i found out this show
would no longer be moving forward this
happened even after they already made
their first episode but i don't think we
ever actually found out why this show
about the long night was ultimately shut
down
well thanks to james andrew miller's new
book some new information has been
revealed about what happened behind the
scenes at hbo during their ruthless
pursuit of new frontiers during an
interview with james andrew miller
warner media's chairman bob greenblatt
revealed what happened with the canceled
game of thrones show he said they had
spent over 30 million dollars on a game
of thrones successor show that was in
development when i got there and when i
saw a cut of it after a few months after
i arrived i said to casey this just
doesn't work and i don't think it
delivers on the promise of the original
series and he didn't disagree which was
actually a relief now this obviously
sounds a little vague but it seems like
the long night series did not have that
look and feel of a game of thrones
caliber show what is most shocking about
these developments is the fact that they
shelled out over 30 million dollars for
this one episode only for it to get shut
down anyway some of you may not know
this but the same thing nearly happened
when dan and dave made their first
episode for game of thrones
hbo almost shut everything down before
game of thrones even got off the ground
but dan and dave were given a second
crack at it and during their second
attempt they obviously got it right and
as we all know game of thrones went on
to become one of the most successful
shows in television history now for hbo
to hand over 30 million dollars for the
pilot episode of the long night and
still shut it down anyway lets me know
that it must have been really awful
just to give you an idea of how much
that actually is hbo only spent about a
third of this on the original pilot for
game of thrones think about it this way
the entire budget for all of season 8
was roughly 90 million dollars and that
had massive battles like the battle of
winterfell as well as king's landing
that's 90 million dollars for six
episodes whereas hbo handed over 30
million dollars for the long night
episode that will never see the light of
day that's absolutely insane
in this interview bob greenblatt goes on
to say we unfortunately decided to shut
down the successor show about the long
night he said there was enormous
pressure to get it right and i don't
think that show would have worked the
pilot episode of the unreleased game of
thrones series was filmed in northern
ireland back in 2019 but it was
ultimately shelved however hbo did
announce that a separate show the
upcoming game of thrones house of the
dragon had been given the green light
now at the time of these announcements
no further details were given about the
cancelled show but now it looks like it
was a very expensive mistake for hbo
however things are said to be going well
in the developmental phase for house of
the dragon greenblatt also said i'm the
one who encouraged kc to greenlight at
the series
he said let's not risk 30 million
dollars on one episode we can't spend 30
million dollars on a pilot just for it
not to get green lit let's not do it
that way this time
let's get a great show that we feel good
about and just make it or not so this is
exactly why house of the dragon was
immediately given a full series order
right after the long night series was
officially shut down let's just hope
this means they actually followed
through with what they had in mind let's
hope this means they actually feel
really good about house of the dragon
since they did not order a pilot episode
but instead ordered the entire first
season now we will just have to wait and
see exactly how good it actually is when
it airs on hbo max next year
we should see that first episode
somewhere around april as always make
sure you subscribe now if you want to
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding game of thrones
house of the dragon or anything else set
within the song of ice and fire universe
there will be more videos very soon i
want to thank all of you for stopping by
to watch this one i hope everyone has a
great day i will be seeing you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you